this is the Jocko underground podcast
sitting here with EC Echo Charles sure
and me Draco one like
the open mind
which is good and self self-doubt
self-doubt so people freak out a little
bit about self-doubt and sometimes it
consumes them right uh some people will
try and discourage you from having any
self-doubt like you gotta believe in
yourself right
for me self-doubt is
not only not only okay but
kind of good
in a way and and I was listening to BJ
Penn on Joe Rogan's podcast
and Ro Rogan started talking about Mike
Tyson who was training with custom auto
and Custom Auto was actually that's over
that that whole thing is crazy you start
that I guess they're turning that into a
movie right now I don't know how they're
gonna pull it off but
custom motto was
he guided Mike Tyson so like perfectly
to become the champ
by talking to him and by
explaining things psychologically and
kind of like hypnotizing him and just
influencing him so
so powerfully you know that Mike Tyson
was a machine right he turned into a
machine
so one of the things he said was was
and again this is a quote from Rogan
which is a quote from Gus to my custom
auto so who knows how uh perfect I'm
gonna get it but the basic quote is fear
is like fire it can warm it can warm and
cook your food warm you and it can cook
your food
or it can burn your house down right so
this is also clearly a dichotomy right
but I think it's the same with self Self
Doubt
because if you're if you have some
self-doubt
it's gonna be good because you're
pushing you're like training a little
extra you're gonna prepare a little bit
more
but it can also right so if you if
you're going in a jiu jitsu tournament
and you have self-doubt you're gonna
like train extra hard and do some cardio
and you're gonna lift weights and you're
gonna work on your wrestling you're
doing work if you think you're gonna go
in there and dominate you know you're
backing off and it's the same thing with
anything in life
but also you could not enter the
tournament right you could be so freaked
out that you're not gonna end it or
you're not going to go for the job
interview or you're not going to go talk
to your boss about getting a raise like
none of that stuff's gonna happen
because you're doubting it and so you
got to find that balance
but
so so now to kind of go a little
tangential for me I have a another kind
of self-doubt which is also kind of
positive in my opinion which is when
someone pushes back against me when
someone's got some other idea that I
don't agree with
I think to myself okay what do I what do
I not understand so if I say hey Echo
here's the plan for what we do today
tonight and you say
I don't like that plan
I don't think you're bad I don't think
you're an idiot I think what is it that
I don't see why don't why why does Echo
see something that I don't see and this
actually opens my mind so for me
self-doubt is a
is a
state of mind that actually opens up my
mind and allows me to
listen
now here's here's here's the thing about
having the open mind I've been talking
to a lot of people a lot of clients
about this
your mind is the natural mode of
operating for your mind is to close
that's the natural mode of operating why
because it's safer because it's easier
because it's more comfortable so the
minute you have to open your mind up to
someone else's ideas it gets gonna get
uncomfortable
the minute you open up this your mind to
someone else's ideas things are getting
harder because you gotta take in what
they're saying you got to do this
calculus
just like uh bacteria right we have we
have we're afraid of bacteria we're
afraid of snakes we stay away from them
that's what a new idea is it's a snake
that's going to get in your head so the
natural thing to do is to close our
minds
and so it's difficult to go through life
because if you don't pay attention your
mind's your mind is constantly just
trying to get closed back up and try not
to let any other ideas in
and clearly this is
a pandemic right now out in the world
because people's minds are just boom
boom closing closing closing
and it's
it's
you have to pay attention to it so you
actually have to detach to see that your
mind is closed right you won't see it on
your own you won't see it
if you're not thinking about it if
you're not consciously trying to pull
back and check where your brain is at
where your mind is at it's going to be
closed and you can just be running
around just not knowing that your mind
is closed you're just how will you know
it you won't know it
you won't know it it's like there's no
interference coming in to let you know
hey
your mind is closed and occasionally you
get rocked with some radical idea I mean
can you imagine the guys that were doing
like
whatever traditional martial art in 1989
and how crazy it was for someone to come
in and take them down and choke them
with us
you know like how crazy was it when they
threw their magic strike and they it
didn't work at all and then this guy
just grabbed him and hip tossed them or
double legged them and then all of a
sudden they're getting choked and and
they their their mind is so closed you
know what they say immediately
let's try that again the only people
I've had say that to me especially in
the early days of Jiu Jitsu like I would
roll with somebody and they let's try
that again their mind couldn't couldn't
even accept what was happening normally
I don't know what you found it would be
like three to five submissions before
someone actually understands that
there's something going on here that
they don't get before their mind even
cracks barely open it takes them getting
submitted three to five times yeah
before they even recognize this
yes uh makes sense
um but yeah I don't have a concrete
number there you've never I mean how
many times you have somebody like oh
let's see yeah the only to be honest the
only time that's ever happened where
someone would be like oh let's go again
like they didn't like Believe it or they
thought oh I just fell down in a bad
spot or something like that it's like at
like a party or something at a barbecue
that can say those counts man yeah yeah
well I would definitely end up in more
uh let's say direct yeah because you
know I'm in the I'm in the dirt so we
got everyone that's thinking that they
know some stuff yeah especially because
dude I mean I'm in the teams with guys
that were you know 80s guys yeah
and 90s guys that are like hey we
learned that if you do this yeah you're
100 gonna go down it's like okay do it
to me yeah double leg rear naked choke
yeah but it takes so so you get you
choke someone once twice three times
their mind's not even open yet they're
still like that was like you said uh you
just fell down you got lucky and it
would take that multiple attacks and
submissions before their mind even gets
a little bit open and then normally like
a half an hour like oh let's let's go
one more they like it closes back up
again
so that happens to all of us and it's
it's unnatural
to keep your mind open it's unnatural
it's not it's not the human mode of
operating to open up to listen to what
other people have to say
and
yet if you can do it if you can go
through life
keeping that thing like taking a stick
and putting it in your mind and so that
the little hatch is pried open and it's
stuck open
you're gonna you're gonna have such a
easier time
understanding other people understanding
other ideas
and coming to a better conclusion that's
that's going to be
that's going to make everything in your
life better yeah
yeah just knowing that I think is the
because you forget just like how you
said like you're my even if because even
if you do open your mind for a second
bit okay I'll have an open mind on this
one and then you accept the idea then
close right back up even if you accept
the idea I was like oh yeah I had an
open mind accepted the idea I even
changed my mind look how mature look at
my growth and then you just close your
mind again it's like a it's an ongoing
campaign you got to kind of keep your
mind open or get in the habit of keeping
it open well what's crazy now is you
know when you watch the divisiveness in
the country people are
people will get presented with quote
facts and here's the thing though like
those facts are just wrong and they'll
present their other quote facts and so
you have people debating with facts
about I just don't even believe your
facts at all so I'm just not listening
to anything that you say yeah and and
it's wildness yeah but you're right
though if you're in it or whatever
that's like that's like a natural thing
I mean the the stuff that's coming out
of Ukraine right now it's it's
the the Russians and the ukrainians
everyone's doing this massive sort of
information
operations push to get out their stories
and I mean the the one example that came
out of the gate was the Ghost of Kiev
were you tracking that the ghost of Kiev
hey this great Ukrainian pilot shot down
X number of Russian aircraft and
everyone's all hyped on it and yeah it's
just it just wasn't true and yeah so
it's it's been interesting to see how
that is but it's also that's going into
another topic of like hey you better
well I've talked about this before you
know it's a first report you better take
it with a little grain of salt yeah yeah
but that open mind thing is cut and you
say it's like natural and it is just
like but it's essentially kind of like
exercise we'll say lifting weights Rob
Jones actually talks about this where
it's like you can look at weights or new
ideas or whatever however kind of in two
ways where it's up to you where you can
be like oh yeah I'm gonna be resistant
to it like I don't want to go lifting
weights is hard I'm not gonna do that my
body doesn't I'm not in the mood to do
all that but if you do it don't look at
it as like some imposition onto you look
at it as something that you can use to
adapt to and then become stronger so
same thing with the ideas if you're a
close mind that's like you just not
wanting to lift weights or whatever
because it's too hard it's too heavy
you're tired whatever
and that's essentially your body trying
to be efficient I think that's like
really what it is yeah and I think as
you said I think the worst case of this
is just that you don't
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground